I keep getting asked this type of
question how do I get discipline or how
do I want discipline the only way to
break a habit you guys is not to deal
with the triggers avoiding temptation is
a way of life by doing one thing
differently you can avoid all kind of
temptation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's live your
best believed life and learn the five
proven ways to develop unbreakable
self-discipline also if you want to know
what Jocko Willick Mel Robbins Jordan
Peterson and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
people want to know how to stop the
laziness and they want to know how to
stop the procrastination I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see if you're gonna speak effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with way number
one envision the results with Jocko
willing I keep getting asked this type
of question how do I get discipline or
how do I want discipline or how do I
maintain discipline and the answer it's
it's a simple answer but obviously it's
not easy and there's all kinds of little
tricks and methods that people talk
about and you know they have some merit
you know maybe they do work these these
things you know do the little things
people say and wake up early I say that
and write things down and take cold
showers and tell everyone what you're
going to do so broadcast it and make
promises or or make bets with with your
friends of something that you don't want
to lose and those things those ideas
they're cool I'm sure they're gonna have
some impact and if they work for you
that's that's awesome but the fact of
the matter is that the reason discipline
is hard to maintain is because it is
hard to maintain that's what makes
discipline hard it's hard and if you
hear me claim that discipline is easy
for me then straight up
that's just my ego talking that's what
that is because I'm unfortunately just
as human as everyone else and it is work
to maintain the discipline that's what
it is work holding the line maintaining
the standard giving no slack none that's
the discipline that's the discipline and
it is hard
and if there's one thing I would say
that does make it easier it's to
envision what it feels like when you're
done what it feels like after you've
worked out or you've held the line on
your food intake or you've pushed
through some monotonous project that you
have to do and all those things when
they're done that they feel good and
contrary to that envision what you will
feel like later when you let the
discipline slack you know the feeling
feeling weak and defeated and you know
that you're falling behind so get to
know those two different types of
feelings and ask yourself which one you
want to feel in ten minutes or in a half
an hour when when the thing is done when
the discipline has blend implemented
remember what that feels like
and then remember that those minutes and
those hours they turn into weeks and
months and years and holding the line in
those critical minutes will put you in
an infinitely better place physically
and mentally if you maintain the
discipline so work through the weakness
fight through the temptation hold the
line
hold the line
maintain the discipline it is not easy
[Music]
but it is worth it because yes because
discipline equals freedom we number to
interrupt the pattern of procrastinating
with Mel Robbins you're not a
procrastinator you have a habit of
procrastinating big difference because
if it's a habit I can teach you to use
science to break it you see all habits
have three parts there's a trigger and
in the case of procrastination the
triggers always stress then there's a
pattern you repeat and in the case of
procrastination it is to avoid doing
something and then there's a reward you
get a little stress release the only way
to break a habit you guys is not to deal
with the triggers you're never gonna get
rid of the stress in your life but you
can 100% change your pattern of avoiding
work so next time that you're in a
situation where you feel yourself
hesitate you spent way too much time
checking out the highlights from last
night's scores what you're gonna do is
you're gonna go up I must be stressed
out about something acknowledge the
stress then go 5 4 3 2 1 I want you to
count yourself because I want you to
interrupt the habit that's stored here
and I want you to awaken your prefrontal
cortex then I want you to just work just
for five minutes the reason why I want
you to only work for five minutes is
because your problem isn't working it's
the habit of avoiding I just need you to
start and here's the other cool thing we
know based on research that if we can
get you to start 80% of you are going to
keep going we number three remove
temptation with Terry Crews remove
temptation you must remove temptations
if you are going to have self-discipline
I'm trying to say if you are trying to
lose weight if you are trying to get
better if you are trying to do things in
a good good way you have to remove the
temptations me I had a problem with
pornography
years ago and now it's one of those
things that I had to eliminate
temptations I had to eliminate things
that I felt would trigger me and get me
back or going on the wrong path and it's
really really subtle one of the things
that's by examining what the way you
think and how you act in a given
situation I find that there were times
like Friday night is when I felt like
that was the time to view pornography
you know why because I remember everyone
going out on Friday and it feeling real
sexy and feeling like whoo and women and
this dancing partying and all that and
then I would I would do it I've said no
I'm not gonna do that I'm a good boy but
I'm gonna stay home and I'm gonna watch
porn which was a horrible horrible habit
so Friday night I know when those
feelings are coming and when that I get
sensitive and I feel like mmm you know
this might be the time to click on
something you know what I mean and I
know it and I head it off at the pass
you just make sure that you know where
you are and you avoid those temptations
the same thing with eating if you know
you have a problem with donuts do not go
to the donut shop to get your coffee you
know I mean go to a place that doesn't
have Donuts or something that you know
is your vice that you know you shouldn't
do another thing you can be proactive
when I say avoiding temptation if you
want to really consistently make the gym
a part of your life set your clothes out
for the gym the night before and it will
remove the temptation to not go to the
gym when you wake up you're all of a
sudden you have your clothes there and
you just hop in them instead of looking
all over the house I can't find my shirt
I can't find my socks I don't know
what's going on you'll have your clothes
there and there will be no excuse for
you not to go avoiding temptation is a
way of life by doing one thing
differently you can avoid all kind of
temptation and it was the key to your
self-discipline we number four
strengthen your mind with Aubrey Marcus
big thing that makes a good day versus
not a good day is exposure to cold
really yeah like wim HOF style you mean
it's not it's not a good day if you're
not exposed to cold it's not as good a
day really it's not as there's something
about that not only pushing yourself I
do it early in the morning and you can
either do it in the shower but start
with a warm shower start doing the wim
hof breathing which starts to hyper
oxygenate the body also has a lot of
health benefits and then turning that
shower nozzle cold and how long for
about three minutes is what you want to
do all the way cold and if you have a
cold pool or cold baths you can do that
but it's twofold one it's gonna reduce
your chronic stress so norepinephrine
goes up adrenaline goes up and it drops
your cortisol so it drops the baseline
of stress that we all carry all the time
but the other thing is it's that moment
right before you turn that nozzle where
every part of he's like man not to pick
up beer you're like I don't want to do
don't want to do that you turn it over
secondly exactly exactly
even though you know it's not gonna hurt
you even though you know it's gonna
benefit you it's gonna develop cold
shock proteins it's gonna help your
immune system you know people exposed to
cold get 43% less respiratory infections
like it's oppositely of the wives tales
that we've heard like don't go out in
the cold you'll you'll get sick like
regular and mediated exposure to cold is
actually going to help your immune
system so even with all the pen it's
gonna boost the immune system boost the
more you do it yeah so you believe when
we have the discipline to put ourselves
through controlled stress for a few
minutes it's going to give us extreme
benefits the rest of the day no doubt
because it's the same thing like when
we're thinking about whether we want to
work out or not right right we're
sitting around like yeah you know I
really should go out and take that run I
really should go out and take that
workout we know we're gonna feel better
when we do it we know we're gonna be
better but what is that part of
ourselves that's gonna turn that little
bit extra over to the yes column you
know it's something I call mental
override and I talked about it in the
book it's the ability to use your mind
to give you that little extra to push
you into yes mental override yeah and it
same thing that you would same thing
that you would use with you need to
start that project or if you're screwing
around on emails and need to actually
get to the meat of the problem at work
it's that same mental technique that's
gonna allow you to kill it but you get
to practice that in the morning and you
get to have that small win so that the
next time you're facing that off I
really should start that big project I
really should work on this you just have
that same attitude like I'm gonna do it
yeah and way number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip is make
a proper schedule with Jordan B Peterson
make a damn schedule and stick to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison that's
the first thing that people do wrong is
well I don't like to have follow a
schedule it's like well what kind of
schedule are you setting up well I
should I have to do this then I have to
do this then I have to do this you know
and then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do
it's like wrong set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want that's
the trick it's like okay I've got
tomorrow if I was gonna set it up so it
was the best possible day I could have
practically speaking what would it look
like well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's gonna go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're gonna
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you burn yourself and it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20% of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well I've got
these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you go I
work tomorrow okay so I want you to work
tomorrow and you might say okay well
what are you gonna do for me that makes
it likely that I'll work for you well
you could ask yourself that you know
maybe you'd do an hour of responsibility
and then you play a video game for 15
minutes I don't know whatever turns your
crank man but you know you
have to negotiate with yourself and not
tyrannize yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life and and that's how
you make the schedule it's like and then
you look at the day and you think well
if I had that day that I'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 percent accuracy but
that beats the hell out of zero right
and if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy
another rule is well aim for 51 percent
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for God's sake or because you're gonna
hit that position where things start to
loop back positively and spiral you
upward
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Will Smith on how to develop
self-discipline that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
question it's time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your replies in the comments below
here we go question number one what
needs to change in your schedule to help
you better reach your goals
number two how will you strengthen your
mind so you can keep to your schedule
and number three what temptations do you
need to remove so that you can stay on
track
so I do
screamed to me the other night hey will
I wanna be active man I won't be active
just like you
you know usually people say stuff to me
like that I'm like yeah man you know you
doing give them an encouraging word but
I was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something as simple as food and eating
it is not about your your body as much
as it is about your mind it's getting
command of your mind to be able to
choose actions that are in your own best
interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so you
gonna kick yourself in the balls so you
will stop yourself from getting what you
dream self-discipline is the center of
all material success you cannot win the
war against the world if you can't win
the war against your own mind the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon
[Music]
if you like this video check that the 20
pieces of advice every aspiring
entrepreneur needs to hear video it's
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there and to work on the
alignment of your personality